you and nakamura are both in the top of  the table  uh and we did talk about the two of you  as  the the favorites to this tour uh are  you  does this mean that both of you are  playing your best chess  now um i mean not necessarily but i  think he played  he played well in in this game and  eventually put me under quite a bit of  pressure um and  i yeah maybe he even had some chances at  some point but i certainly had to fight  to  um to survive so i think yeah i  uh he definitely um definitely played a  good game  how will you sum up your day today um  i think a little bit worse than than  yesterday um  to be honest with the pairings i had  today i would have hoped to score  to score a half a point more maybe but  um so it's  it's fine yeah and you're still at the  top of the table  uh are you happy with that no of course  uh the the score is very decent  um and with a good finish tomorrow i'll  get i'll get the  top seed so i'm definitely gunning for  that  great thank you